هناك حماس وهناك جمهور كبير يستعد لهذه
المباراه التي ستقام هنا في هذا ستاد
مدينه المدينه الاعلاميه او دوكيشن سيتي
هنا في الدوحه والتي ستنطلق وبين بولندا
والسعوديه طبعا ممكن نشوف
كيف يواجهه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كيف هو الحماس وكيف هو الجمهور والجمهور
دائما هنا هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والله يا صالح
[تصفيق]
الامير محمد بن سلمان
تستمتعه ما عندنا خساره نحنا دايما قدام
واليوم نحنا بملحمه عربيه اسلاميه قويه
بعيد عن كل انواع كره القدم اليوم نعيش
اسره واحده بعد فوز السعوديه اكتشفنا ان
العرب والمسلمين قلب واحد وان شاء الله
قدام وقدام صلاح والتنظيم رائع وكل شيء في
البطوله رائع صراحه توقعاتي 1-0 للسعوديه
باذن الله فرحتنا اليوم
اثنين واحد السعوديه
[تصفيق]